notre association s'intéresse
spécifiquement la lutte contre
l'exposition involontaire c'est à dire
l'exposition qui n'est pas recherché et
qui dans bien des cas est la première
exposition
cette exposition a lieu essentiellement
sur des sites non pornographique
donc soit des sites de streaming par
exemple avec des fenêtres pop up mais
également via des smartphones grâce aux
messageries instantanées aux différentes
applications qui permettent de
transférer des images entre amis est
tout simplement dans la cour de
récréation comme l'évoquait l'instant
olivier la diffusion du téléphone
portable dans les cours de récréation
fait que dès l'école primaire il suffit
que l'un des camarades de votre enfant
et un téléphone portable pour que votre
enfant ait accès au contenu de ce
téléphone portable
les chiffres que vous évoquez sont
inquiétants et je crois qu'il faut
garder à l'esprit qu'ils sont assez
optimistes par rapport à la réalité du
terrain olivier thomas rappelait qu'il y
à une aggravation de la situation je me
souviens que lorsque nous avions
animé avec olivier des réunions pour la
création du site je protège mon enfant
point gouv.fr l'ensemble des acteurs
associatifs présents s'accordaient à
dire que la première exposition avait
lieu aux primaires aux alentours de 8
ans et que
dans l'ensemble un enfant sur deux avait
déjà eu accès à du contenu
pornographique
en primaire les différents sondages nous
donnent un premier regard mais gardant à
l'esprit que ce regard est
que partiel etc la réalité certainement
beaucoup plus grave
cette réalité
c'est la réalité dont d'une exposition
précoce qui va banaliser le fait
sexuelle cette banalisation du fai
sexuelles à des effets sur l'enfant et
les effets sur la société
la semaine dernière encore différents
articles sont sortis dans la presse sur
la prostitution des jeunes filles dès
l'âge de 13 ans
13-14 ans des jeunes filles qui sont
recrutés viasna chat via instagram via
tik tok et qui vont
à leur sens ne pas faire la prostitution
mais techniquement soit pratiquée dès ce
qu'on appelle des calmes donc être sur
des sites où elles vont réaliser des
actes sexuels devant un public derrière
son écran soit de manière plus triviale
se prostituer au sens propre du terme
cette possibilité pour des enfants
très jeunes 13 ans ça reste quand même
jeune
d'accepter de faire cela démontre qu'il
ya une banalisation du fait sexuelle que
finalement cela n'a rien d'exceptionnel
et que c'est assez courant en tous les
cas beaucoup plus courant que ce que
nous nous nous pensons et certainement
encore beaucoup moins enfin de manière
beaucoup plus éloigné de ce que les
parents de ces enfants en pense il y a
donc à notre sens un lien quand même
assez manifeste entre la précocité de
l'exposition à la pornographie la
banalisation des contenus
pornographiques
une certaine accoutumance voir
dépendance à ces contenus est une
reproduction dans le monde réel de ce
qui est vu sur les sites pornographiques